do what you love and make sure Money
Follows you there are so many Starving
Artists they do what they love but that
doesn't necessarily mean that they can
make money so you have to make sure it's
two different things but I think if you
do what you love definitely you'll
become happier and less stressed and
you'll be more attractive as a person
and that person has a better chance of
making money if they choose to just once
again forget about the money part
because making money is just uh I'd say
a one of 14 fields in that life you know
your self-image or your sense of
contribution uh you know connectedness
sense of being connected with nature is
often forgotten in Western World there
are many fields of Happiness if you
focus only one or two with business and
money you tend you cannot see all the
other 12 for example need motivation
Hey Kevin Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today this one from
one of the best Ken Honda and my take on
this top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two identify your skills you
have to know where your gifts are you
know you may be good at speaking writing
cooking you have to identify what is uh
like two or three things that you're
super good at so just start finding what
you're super good at and the second
system uh second is build up your own
business model big business system for
example
the reason why that my publisher prints
uh 50 000 copies at the beginning is
that I have so many fanbase you know I
have about a half a million people on my
list and uh when I just talk about my
book I get views of uh my book uh a
podcast is uh download of 48 million
downloads you know so uh so I have that
fan base so if you are have that long uh
strong foundation and also have a
subscription uh system uh it's one of
the largest online Salon we have about
12 000 membership uh each paying ten
dollars a month oh I and I started out
the salmon in English it's called
Arigato Living Community we have the at
the beginning 500 people but I think
it's going to grow so if you have the
base set up a system so people can
support you like say uh people uh could
be in Azerbaijan or Congo or in China
Whoever likes my material they're all
gonna buy my books and also they're
gonna become a Community member so if
you have a business model
you have a strong base people start
paying you and and if you have a strong
connection with the members and people
they're going to keep supporting you and
if you don't betray them they're going
to come back as a royal customer so for
me I publish many books right so when I
publish uh my next book people are gonna
order pre-order without knowing what is
in it yeah it's like a chef you know
Chef is going to cook something you
don't know what but you trust Chef
enough to to just order a food in
advance
so chef's special if you do a chef
special in your own area how many people
are gonna buy you know is it like your
friend your best friend and your mom you
know that's not enough right so just
start improving your gifts build this
business model and just build a strong
deep connection with people
some of my readers are like 20 years old
and they're now passing down my books to
their yeah to to the children
so if that happens
uh you have uh the Next Generation
people coming in right so the stronger
the base uh the higher your income so uh
if your base is like uh say 100 000
people or ten thousand people or like 50
million people you know that will decide
how much you're gonna make so how have a
strong trustworthy relationship with
your customers and friends and that is
the beginning to your first million
dollars rule number three is help others
money is energy if you help money comes
so I talk about this
um in a very casual way uh my uh early
career as a self-help author and also
teacher started from uh Denny's you know
I retired for four years from for my
baby so during the time day time I had a
lot of time because I had a babysitter
and also um person helping with cleaning
and everything right so
um uh I spent a couple of hours with my
friends and my friends friends who
wanted to see me and learn about
happiness and money so I I always talk
about uh giving and receiving and the
Happy Money the principles of happy
money and all the other things
and I get tired of just repeating the
same thing because I have to explain
about my ideas it takes about 10 15
minutes so I decided to record the the
most important basic 15 minutes and then
um started Distributing the CD for free
so if you want to see me just listen to
this city so the basic is covered and my
other 45 minutes can be well spent and
by the way I didn't charge anything you
know they just bought me lunch and
dinner
but that that's all but I was so happy
to share my idea and I distributed the
10 page uh booklet along with that so I
so I'm I put it in one one envelope and
I started giving away as a gift
and that caught fire there are so many
people wanted to have my freak CD and
also a booklet uh for free and I hire
the printer and I printed uh 3000
instead of 500 which I originally asked
because he's a good salesperson and uh
he said it it
goes uh the cost of printing goes
dramatically low if you uh print three
thousand but he didn't pay he didn't
tell me how many boxes it's gonna be so
they're there done that
a lot of boxes he didn't tell me you
know and uh but so I I was so upset and
I apologize my wife for uh for making a
mistake uh in uh order placing an order
and I said uh I'll uh I'll promise to
get rid of boxes in three months and
he's she smiled and said one month
boxes out or you out okay and I started
giving away my booklets and uh people
really loved it so and next time I
printed another three thousand another
five thousand uh and I was I became
smart enough to uh have a storage unit
somewhere
and I hire one secretary I was so happy
to do that for free I didn't charge
anything uh I I had some money uh from
investing so I started uh spending the
money and by the time I gave away 100
000 copies a publisher called me and
they asked me to write a book which I
said no because I wrote everything in
this 26 pages I don't think uh anything
else will come out but he said but you
have all the time in the world why don't
you sit in front of your computer
something may come out which I did and
then a lot came out so by the time I
um finished my first book uh three more
books came into my head and the rest of
the history I published about uh 200
books and sold more than 80 and a half
cup million copies so far rule number
four is use your money well everybody
can relate to this when we spend money
we'll lose money you know so uh for
example when you when we pay kids
tuition uh School tuition if we do that
out of gratitude that becomes happy
money well what we feel like we are
losing money for tuition which is not a
healthy attitude you know the money we
spend uh enriches somebody's life and
then it'll Circle back to us
so it's almost like a um food when we
eat and if we don't want to release it
you're not healthy you know because you
hold on to the food I don't want to let
go you know I don't want to go to the
bathroom I want to hang on to what I ate
which is not a healthy attitude so
um you have to eat well and release well
that is the basics of our health and at
the same time for your Financial Health
receiving money well and releasing money
well is the attitude so um when you take
a look at your financial life we are in
the flow of money so to make your money
uh flow happier more steadily more
steadily is the key instead of holding
on to the money we spend
you know money has a certain
nature a certain character a certain
energy about it doesn't it it does it
does tell us about that
money itself is a neutral energy but if
you think money is God money becomes God
if you think money is a Monster who
hurts people because we we know whom
often hurt by money we think when we are
small our parents deny our summer
schools because of money or certain
dreams or crafts because of money so
money turns into the thing we we think
it is so unless you deal and heal our
money owns uh our concept and beliefs
belief about money does not change also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is aim for
happiness you really have to figure out
what you want in your life do you want
to do you want to make it uh do you want
to be a success socially
but you could become you could end up
being a loser personally so do you want
to be a a happy person or do you want to
be a wealthy person you can take both
but uh the way to happy and wealthy
people
only has an opening uh through aim for
happiness first I love this because most
people think once I'm there then I'll be
happy then I'll respect myself then I'll
get the attention I want but what I'm
hearing you say is the only way to happy
and wealthy is through happiness first
yes and then if you're lucky or if it's
your destiny I would say you may be
rewarded with money but you know there
are many lives that
necessarily money will follow
but you can still enjoy life and stay
very happy because if you go after money
you you could you're likely to lose
everything your peace of mind and those
people who who put money first uh you
would your clients love that you know
just uh um think about two florists by
the way I always carry uh flowers like
this you know
um in front of me so uh there are two
florists for example
um just nearby your house one florist
always think of the cost instead of 10
roses I should I should give nine roses
you know instead of good roses maybe
smaller ones so they can cut costs right
the other florist always just bring in
the best flowers and always take good
care of it so that it will last on on
their houses
where would you go you know so if you
are good at math and good at business uh
in the short term they will lose long
term
so people who love flowers and then uh
he or she can
talk about the roses for hours those
people
really care
that um you just they care about the
Roses uh on uh in your house you know
they're just praying their kids will
stay longer so you know people can enjoy
and you know they're not they might
think about the cost but the love of the
flowers is bigger you know than the
business but those people are the ones
that I think all the clients would go to
So eventually they will succeed rule
number six avoid greed energy money can
be either good or bad so it's a he
showed me my father
um showed me a coin uh and and he showed
me both sides you know money is
interesting
um one side
God the other side devil you know which
uh whatever you draw it becomes a
reality for you so if you want money to
be God God can do anything for you but
if you just pull out the worst part of
money your life will be uh in hell so
it's up to you
so he didn't really mention about happy
money in in in in the sense I'm using
but in his own way he said uh you have
to make other people happy and receive
money otherwise if you say you can make
money by taking an advantage of other
people uh So you you're doing it out of
greed and that great energy and anger
energy
comes with money so you feel Restless at
home uh I know you cannot
um feel so peaceful so you have to have
alarm system everywhere you know you
have to protect yourself but if you made
everybody happy and make made a lot of
money you can have a very good night's
sleep
um which I I'm doing right now uh I just
um remember how many people uh I I
helped that day
and I just start imagining uh who were
my readers my books sell about a few
thousand copies uh every day all over
the world and so um I must have helped
at least a few thousand people uh with
my books and also with my um YouTube and
everything I'm helping um thousands of
people every day so I just imagine faces
of people who have who whom I have
helped on that day and just I feel so
blessed and then in about five minutes
or 10 minutes I go to sleep with joy but
if you're just taking advantage of other
people and make money
yeah they're kind of haunting haunting
you energy wise so unless you kind of
like shut them out you cannot go to
sleep it makes me think of I don't know
ghosts and money
so if you just uh try to take advantage
of other people and and Rob them of
their money uh it becomes ghost on your
money which is not so fun so it does all
kind of tricky things uh it uh you know
I've seen so many uh kids uh from
gangster family uh suffer so much
because of the messed up energy from
money so that's why I call uh Happy
money laundering is very important rule
number seven appreciate paying taxes
when you pay something to somebody that
means you're getting some kind of
service or Goods right exchange for
money but not always sometimes you just
get ripped off right that's true yeah or
but you're you're getting a learning
experiences
yeah so like uh oftentimes you can
appreciate uh uh this exchange uh
because you you know um at the
restaurant they may serve you or you get
electricity for the money and then you
have a choice you can complain about it
you can thank it for example taxes is a
big thing I said uh yeah I understand
your concept but I have a hard time
appreciating the government because
they're wasting my money and he said do
you have a choice not paying the taxes I
said probably not
so he said if you don't have a choice
it's your choice
you complain it you'll appreciate it and
and he said uh you know I know uh
they're not uh using the tax money right
but at the same time uh your money is
used used to pay Bros pay for the police
people and hospitals and Kids Care so
your money is doing some good you know
when it when it gets handed over to
government right so since then I started
appreciating
um about paying taxes so I'm one of the
very few people on this planet who love
paying taxes
yeah that means that you made enough
money
to be able to pay taxes and somehow uh
the more taxes I I started paying the
more income and more opportunities I
started to attract so I don't care so
much about paying taxes or paying bills
anymore because uh it gives me joy rule
number eight is shift your gifts you
have a unique relationship with your
daughter and so as a parent how would
you teach kids how are you teaching kids
about money so she's witnessed
um how I became successful in in this
book industry
so I always told her
um by sharing your gifts and by sharing
what you love
uh money uh you get rewarded financially
and so uh she and also she's witnessed
uh so many people starting from scratch
as my student and then they become at
the ended up becoming a millionaire so
they were just wearing you know shabby
clothes but a few years later during you
know like a Chanel and the kind of a
cruise Sunday yeah so she noticed the
difference right and so she asked me all
the questions like Daddy what changed
her and you know I talk about self-image
and all that so um she's starting out as
a singer and she's uh just that started
but uh her YouTube views are more than
50 000 times uh over a few months uh her
name is Stella yeah
so you know she's really enjoying her a
music career and uh she's making music
and also so she is good at helping
people so I guess she's gonna be like a
singer slash writer slash right
um speaker so because that's her or her
gift lies so I I've always taught her
don't fall money just
um find out what you can do and share
with other people and they will just
bring your money rule number nine is
practice gratitude what can you tell us
about gratitude and how important well
that this I'm going to get Rue the
rooster in a minute it's the chicken in
the egg question gratitude and money
which comes first yeah I mean you can
you can start either way you know you
can stop with gratitude you can start
with money so uh if you receive money
that means that you did something so
um uh your company or your neighbor it
might help do some chores with your
neighbor and then receive money whatever
that is you did something and as a
result you receive money so they showed
you the appreciation for your time and
services so you can start appreciating
on Monday first or you can appreciate
about a roof over your head or the
whatever the things you have in your
house whatever that is is fine so start
from somewhere but you have to change
gears to more uh joy and appreciation
because we are here to share our joy and
gifts with other people and that's I
think that's what we are here for so you
may have 30 years 50 years or 80 years
you know it depends on in the individual
you know God loves somebody so much that
so they want to take
um them away when they're young you know
so I lost my friend a little while ago
and he is one of the most beautiful
human being but uh God loves their
favorite person to be just alongside so
sometimes God does an interesting thing
I don't know how long you're going to be
here but do you want to keep suffering
about about money in life by complaining
or I don't know how many years left uh
you have left in on on this planet but
are you willing to enjoy every second of
it from now so I'm asking you
um it's up to you how you want to uh
spend your time here so if you want to
be more excited and more curious about
life or if you feel like you're uh just
serving the sentences that as a
punishment so you have to just keep
working for a company that you don't
even like you know on surrounded by the
colleagues that you don't even respect
so
it's up to you if you don't like your
situation you can start changing uh a
little by little not just quitting your
job tomorrow
so if you just start doing that you'll
see a little bit of change so but you
have to start from somewhere so I think
gratitude first and then more money
comes so if you uh um appreciate your
money come first and then uh uh Happy
Money may come later and Rule Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is invest in your friends
what anybody can do is investing your
friends you know take your friends out
for dinner uh and then become close uh
closer or just give something to your
clients and and the customers so I think
it's a better investment than investing
in Bitcoins and gold and all the other
things because if if the next financial
crisis happens and then you lose
everything as we said you know go uh go
back to your clients and then start ask
them to start business again and if you
have done some good favors say uh give a
100 worth of something to ten thousand
people
you that's uh one million dollars but
they remember you
so
there's a better chance of getting your
business back
in the next
um
age actually that's what I did 20 years
ago I had an extra one million dollars I
wanted to try it out uh this phonics
experience I already heard of this what
you give will come back to you and I
didn't buy that so okay I'll just test
it so I printed my booklets uh for about
three thousand I started with three
thousand I ended up giving uh 2.3
million copies of my free booklets that
cost me about 3 million US Dollars wow
but anyway
so by the time I gave away my booklets
for about 100 000 copies which cost me
about 100
000 US dollars a publisher called me and
they want me to write a book and I did
which the rest is history here but wow
uh so I gave away my first million
dollar project right and look what
happened uh I sold more than 8 million
copies of my physical books and uh all
my seminars and all the other services
so the the 2.3 Millions I began gave
away came back uh so many times back
so if you have an extra one million
dollars do good for the society do good
for your clients they remember you they
trust you so I had a good reputation
still I do because I gave away my
physical copies for free and I paid even
the postage at that time nobody was
doing it people thought I was crazy now
I was because I wanted I wanted to try
uh this philosophy is that really true
what you give will come back and it it
wasn't true it it came back 10 times
more so you know it's not equal at that
I used to serve a cup of tea for my
father's clients when when I was 9 or
10. I really enjoyed it because I I just
annoyed them with others professional
questions like uh what's your Roe or how
are you making profit in your company
sir you know and they're like oh you
know they feel so intimidated so I
really enjoy giving them uh very
difficult questions and since then I've
seen some entrepreneurs do well and some
entrepreneurs do
um not so good you know even if they're
saying the same age same educational
background uh the their financial
outcome is so different
and I realized that certain people have
uh gifts around making money and others
have this uh blocks and unwillingness to
do business so your attitude toward
money uh is either positive or negative
so uh positive people tend to attract
more money and whereas negative if you
have a negative attitude around money
you tend to lose it you have a hard time
keeping it because you feel
deep inside if money is bad you don't
want any bad thing in your house so I
always often talk about it as a joke
just imagine money as a as a monster or
pet in your house is that like a Pokemon
fun pet in your house or it becomes a
monster that could eat you up be your
parents or your kids if you think money
is scary
you don't want a scary thing in your
house and so if you have uh what is
positive attitude around money you'll be
very good at making money and if you
have some negative
attitude toward money you want to keep
some distance that's why some people are
very good at attracting money other
people like oh I I'm okay with enough
yeah if I uh as long as I can pay all
the bills I'm fine well as long as I'm
on survival mode but still I can survive
I'm okay so it's up to you how
comfortable you feel around money and
business why are so many good people
without the money
it's because they are not interested
it's because they don't care
about money as much as other like
so-called bad people right uh some bad
people are obsessed with money energy
so just think about it if you're just uh
collecting baseball cards and if you're
so into it you want to make sure you get
the collection right and if other people
are not I like the cars but I'm not so
you know I'm not like so picky about
those so I guess uh you know the ones
who are very eager to get those cards
will get them so it that's all uh so uh
it's nothing to do with people being
good uh with a good heart or bad heart
it's just about the the volume of energy
of attachment to money so think about it
if it's like uh collecting Pebbles or
sea sales you know whoever wants to
collect pebbles in your house uh just
think about it if somebody loves
collecting Pebbles from a Riverside
and then stuck them in a closet and then
when you open the closet all the Pebbles
come out like how stupid is that but if
they're obsessed with pebbles
they must have a lot of pebbles in the
closet that's like money you know I'm
I'm using a lot of analogy so I hope you
can get it I had this opportunity to
meet my mentor um later on uh his name
is
so when I asked him to teach about money
he said his first lesson is forget about
money so I'm so confused yeah one of the
things that I found super um confusing
and people so the where I was going is
the notion of a Zen Cohen and this is
something that people probably in the US
anyway be tangentially familiar with the
most famous one we talk about is what is
the sound of one hand clapping
um and there are many Zen cones which
are like Beyond confusing and of course
the idea is once you understand sort of
the absurdity of the question itself and
of course I'm I'm doing this from a
logical perspective and Zen is I think
meant to be very different than that but
um just to give people an anchor Point
once you understand the absurdity of the
question then it's like you're a step
closer to Enlightenment
um so when he said forget about money
what was he what was he trying to get
you to like what does that mean because
obviously it's not truly forget that it
exists yes so what does he mean so I
think him about where I focus
because if you want money you have to
forget about money you have to forget
about what you can give to other people
how much service you can give out to the
world and then you receive money so he
was telling me not to focus on money
because money is the end result of what
we get after serving the world
so instead of focusing on what you get
you have to really focus on what you
give
and and our life is in the middle of
giving and receiving so unless we
receive well and this we we give well we
can receive so we are in the cycle of
appreciation or or resentment
um either cycle you're in
um your life exists so if you start
appreciating your life about everything
including money your life will be filled
with money and appreciation if your life
will be filled with resentment anger and
fear
I run money and I also around life your
life will be also surrounded by life
fear and resentment and anxiety treat
money with respect and and uh whenever
we receive money that's a miracle
because somebody chose you as a client
or a person that to work for so you can
appreciate your boss your clients or the
company you're working for to making a
miracle and just pay you pay you the
money so you can feel thank you thank
you thank you and then uh you know bless
the money uh in a most beautiful way
what's the ultimate goal of having a
good relationship with money is is it
about earning more or is it something
else the key is abundance if you feel
abundant about life so no matter how
much you make how much you you spend if
there's a beautiful flow
and then you know have to be so uptight
about it uh you don't have to be so
careful about it anymore
so that's sort of like a ideal situation
you don't have to be super wealthy in
order to be happy
so uh I think
um you know uh realistically if you just
reach a level of financial happiness
and certain abundance you don't have to
do so many things or all you have to do
is find your gifts find your true
calling and start living it and you
don't have to be super well known or you
don't have to
um you know sell uh millions of products
uh under your name I um ask each one of
you to write down a best friend's name
uh people who can let you stay for a
week or a month and if you have more
than 10 friends you're a lucky person
and I wrote down uh all the uh you know
my friend's name and I they're about uh
about 70 or more
and I realize
if I ask them to let me stay uh with
them for a week you know I can go to my
friend number two and number three and
number four and there are only 52 weeks
uh a year and after 50 friends you can
come back to my your friend number one
and say long time no see can I stay here
again
you don't need any money right so uh
yeah even if you have millions of
dollars in a bank what if somebody sued
you some what if Government gets it what
if there's will be a there will be a
bank Runner what if what if what if you
know the real security lies in the
relationships and friendships and the
people who are who make sure that you're
gonna you're not gonna fall you know
they'll catch you that is the biggest
security so I think
um creating beautiful relations
relationships that like you're you're
teaching is really really the key to
um happiness and also Financial Security
in my mind wealth is uh an emotion
you know it doesn't really matter how
much you have how much you make because
I've interviewed over the course of my
career I've been interviewing
Millionaires and billionaires and some
of them are very unhappy and very upset
with everything I'm sure you've met some
happy ones and very unhappy ones so and
also among the people who are struggling
with life there are also happy people
and unhappy people so I think wealth is
an attitude if you feel like you're so
happy and so content with what you have
you are already wealthy but if you have
uh uh you have if you have to struggle
every day and you cannot find happiness
either in your business or in personal
life I think you're not wealthy even if
you have billions in your bank account
but that doesn't mean that you don't
have to have money I think you're just
focusing on too much visible assets I
often talk about invisible assets
that's that could be your youth your
energy and also your friends and your
ideas and uh your heart you know um we
just um unfortunately we value how much
money you have in your bank account or
how many how how how you own things but
in life there are so many invisible
assets that you can count on so instead
of having so much money in your bank
account
if you have uh 10 good friends who just
let you stay for a week or so you can
keep on living you know I the other day
I I wrote down how many friends I have
and then I realized I have more than 50
friends who can just you know feed me
for a week so you just keep visiting
your friend every week until the next
year comes so you know you can live off
of your friendship for a year that's
Financial Independence so you may think
you're broke uh financially but you may
have other different assets so start
counting what you have if you have a
roof over your head that's you know
that's a great luxury
[Music]
oh
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Dean graziosi
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there listen don't wait
for permission from your husband from
your parents from your children from
anyone remember God gave it to you not
them the universe gave it to you not
them you see I really believe sometimes
our subconscious is really powerful